hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the murder of the king I
will admit I have no idea what this
about it's in my suggestion pile and to
be honest I've recorded a lot today a
whole lot of games today and frankly I
want to play something silly that might
not be good period so here we go I've
never heard of this game in my life and
I'm gonna play it oh my god there's a
lot of levels oh oh it's one of these oh
oh wait what kind of a Sasson am i and
what kind of King is this gonna be oh
good he's dead This Is It this is what I
was getting myself I thought this is
gonna be like a story-driven bull thing
but this is like it's it why do I have a
propeller on my hat I have so many more
questions than I have answers about
what's going on in this place what what
is this how many kings do I have to
assassinate what kind of bizarro world
do I have to do am I the world's
greatest assassin probably because I'm
in medieval times and I got a flying
propeller on my head I mean if that's
not amazing enough by itself and the
fact that I'm murdering all these kings
isn't all that great I mean who's who
goes to their bedroom in this trap
ridden like it's just a make any sense
it oh well oh well I thought that was
gonna kill me I guess it's just okay
that I get captured I mean seriously
what kind of paranoid delusional King
would look ha how would you how would
you go to bed in this bizarro thing all
the time come on with this cheese
[ __ ] going on here if it's gonna
drop it better drop properly and not be
physics-based Bowl oh I'm so glad that
block of cheese has ragdoll physics
huzzah you're dead again I don't know
how many times I'm gonna play this but I
like making fun of it because it's silly
oh no that doesn't kill me that just
that just captures me oh I see how this
is I see the game that it's playing over
here I get what you're putting down just
like I'm putting down these blocks of
cheese like I'm Skyrim guy I don't
remember Dragonborn whatever yeah I
summon wheels cheese whenever you
nevermind you
stupid joke anyway there's like this is
a silly game there's one of those silly
games I'm this one this is one of those
videos were a highly question I'm ever
gonna put this out for everybody to see
so I'm kind of just like it doesn't
matter what kind of commentary that I
put seriously it doesn't matter what
kind of commentary I could say literally
anything because there's more it's more
than likely I'm never ever ever gonna
put this video up on the Internet
because who would watch this who wanna
watch me just playing the stupid game
where I'm a stupid assassin that's just
bubbling his way to stupidness and he's
doing absolutely nothing with his life
this guy is the biggest mmm what why how
wooden oh the King now wake up from that
the King just moved the King moved no
one is that sound of a sleeper the logic
in this game is completely absurd
I mean number one I can give that
there's some mysterious device that
causes my propeller to go perpetually
and havoc has enough enough thrust and
lift to carry my fat ass up this place
but I mean again with the oh come on
with that baloney so we're gonna accept
all this logic about how this that is a
load of crap that is a load of ass if
you're gonna have ragdoll based cheese
and you better have better ragdoll rules
than the [ __ ] that I have to deal
with at this point
I've had it up to here with the
ridiculousness of this game the freaking
slappy du cheese is a bunch of baloney
there's no way this would be realistic
cheese physics in real life I mean the
bubble isn't even lined up properly
where that's supposed to go it's always
as if it wants me to have to rush
yeah you better stay on that button you
cheesy [ __ ] excusable I stab another
King and ruin another country's life I
mean maybe there's just a line of
succession going on with these kings but
I mean I gotta have a problem oh oh
pardon me you have an air cannon you
have an air cannon you have an air Zucca
line of defense is an air Zuka against
the world's greatest assassin I mean I'm
not questioning a lot of things I mean I
am questioning a lot of things but I
question this above all else why do you
have an air cannon and what good would
an air cannon do you against the world's
greatest assassin you gotta admit it's a
bit far-fetched I'm gonna get about this
propeller I can't I can't let this
propeller go this this propellers
regarde am [ __ ] number one first and
foremost this propeller is just regarde
damn dick ulis I mean but but whatever
whatever whatever its its ways whatever
at this point it's whatever the
propellers ridiculous
you'd think is the world's greatest
assassin I would probably not be Jarrod
dressed up as the court jester I mean
that's probably who I am and getting to
this King that sleeps in these trap
filled bedrooms that everyone's dying in
and no one's questioning anything about
who this guy is how he got in because
there's like there's there's no it Oh
apparently these air cannons are a bit
more lethal than the other ones what
about it but but besides that besides
all of that besides everything wrong
with what I'm seeing in front of my face
but besides that besides that why does
the cheese have bad physics why that's
my main problem with all this my main
problem with this like beyond everything
that I've seen thus far and I can
forgive a lot when it comes to games
like this I can forgive a lot but the
logic and the cheese is meaningless huh
I'm tired I need to rant about something
else it's as if someone was trying to
make a game and then just couldn't
decide what ridiculous concept would
allow an assassin to be able to get to a
king because that's all this is like
this is someone trying to be good idea I
wanted her shashin to kill a king over
and over and over again but that was a
little ridiculous so he had to go a few
other steps I mean not that this isn't
ridiculous but I mean come on now thank
you
Oh stabbed maybe someone had a vendetta
against King Edward the third it's some
[ __ ] whatever great but I'm not from
England I don't know anything about it
stop it stop it
no no oh gosh oh gosh I care oh I care
oh I care oh no another dynasty ended it
may be this like hell maybe this is hell
for that King he's just sleeping only to
be awoken every few minutes by someone
stabbing him in the heart and then he
goes back to sleep and I'm in hell
because I got the stupid propeller on my
head and I'm cursed to travel around
flying like a pixie in this world of
mayhem and madness and kill a king over
and over and over again I wouldn't be
surprised if this guy is actually
mysteriously my best friend that makes
sense to me that's probably exactly
what's happened to curse to kill my best
friend over and over the goddamn cheese
physics you got goddamn bird dick
[ __ ] your cheese [ __ ] your [ __ ]
cheese brah
[ __ ] his Green Bay Packer [ __ ] oh
yeah that's right you better oh the
other cheese got me while I was
complaining about the other cheese what
a load of crap oh what a load of ass
good thing I'm almost done with this
stupid game I can't believe I'm almost
playing this game to completion I had no
idea that I was almost playing this game
to completion while I was complaining
about it because I mean god damn if
you're gonna get okay if you're gonna
get one thing why is the cheese spinning
in my hands I mean I get it I get it
physics don't make sense around here but
come on
oh you sack of asses yeah you better
stay down there cheesy [ __ ] you better
say okay hey I did it again I did it I
murdered my king I'm so happy
oh no wait I'm not because I'm still
stuck in a permanent hellhole don't
don't
why not supposed to be here oh oh got
stuck on the button of course the button
was the thing that was gonna get me
stuck I'm not my emotions pardon me
sorry missed me dickbag
Oh Oh missed again what am I supposed to
do here this doesn't make much sense
how would this wait which which button
is the right button
oh that button is the right button well
how do I do that
why can't push that oh I know oh I get
it
okay Hey
okay so that oh come on Oh bull Oh
bow oh there we go that's more like it
it's stupid sack of it ah piss my balls
you suck a dog I hate you I hate you
this is why I want to murder you King if
you are the one true king oh this man
good thing I got this poison fart gas
that's blocking up my vision oh what a
wondrous world this hellhole would be if
I didn't have this poisonous fart gasps
god damn it with your baloney such a
load of asses if I've ever seen the load
of asses in my life and I've seen many
this game I mean I've got qualms
I've got quandary I've got
qualifications Ram it in sedima beep oh
come on just Oh God
the entire last few levels are gonna be
based exclusively on the cheese physics
I bet like eight of my 12 processors in
my computer are just cranked out a
hundred percent to calculate all the
different intricacies of this frickin
block of cheese dodged like a pro die
you bastard
Oh Oh woah canina nother hellhole to
imagine the death of which I have
brought for you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you in
your face ass blast you in your stupid I
forgot those I thought it was a very
pretty gold button that's you think I
want to learn my lesson by now oh you
got me in my face oh this felt so good
yeah I did a lot to me
Thanks excuse me well this one was easy
God do you need to rank your difficulty
a little better because there's no way
that the world's greatest assassin was
gonna be beaten by triviality like that
anyway so I need to get that cheese that
all I got to do that really all I got to
do here oh no I dodged it oh [ __ ] I
didn't dodge it why shouldn't brag so
much about how good I am when I'm not
actually all that good damn it I didn't
see that that one was gonna go God you
suck ass such a pile of [ __ ] what a pile
of kak you know I'm saying pile a cat
going on here oh no oh God
well get I could have gone at that point
there's too late it's too late they came
from behind here okay got it now I go I
got a do is not being douche oh god damn
it
God about that I forgot about that I
forgot about that what a world that I
live in where my worries are full of
farts oh I love this game I loved this
game get stabbed in the dick I'd like to
think I'm stabbing him in the dick every
time I do this oh other humans an
instant death this better be the last
goddamn level or else I'll tell you what
I'll tell you what I'm gonna be happy
about it oh not that hard cheese physics
away God oh wait no no wait no wait no
wait no that's not right hang on here
okay so that guy is supposed damn it
okay that's guys supposed to be okay god
damn cheese physics yes sir why is it
spinning in my hands is the wind from
the propeller of goddamnit that wasn't
the right timing on that there we go
cheese physics ahoy
cheese physics away I got you [ __ ]
you're done you're done so you're gone
you're dead Z's
your dad that better be the last goddamn
one oh you're eating my anus I mean you
got to be kidding me
one or the other I don't know which one
I meant to say it is what it is I got to
stick with my gut at this point what
happened
why'd this happen why this happened why
this happened why did why did it's why
is it on timer so there's the [ __ ]
oh I get it is it it is on a timer okay
so I gotta do this and get that whoa
that was a close one hahaha good thing
I'm good at games not bad
try me bro try me bro you can't beat my
cheese oh you can't be my cheesy
goodness there stay there bro no no no
nah nah no no no no no what now you you
son of a [ __ ] ah you cheesy bastard
[ __ ] you god damn cheese physics my
computer isn't good enough to handle all
these diverse cheese physics don't even
try don't even try bro come at me bro it
ripped
come at me scrublord I'm the world's
greatest assassin there's the original
Assassin's Creed by the way I don't know
ah [ __ ] your farts I'll [ __ ] your
[ __ ] farts [ __ ] your ass blasting far
to Lloyd's whatever I don't know what I
said
goddammit screw your butthole and cheese
physics oh ma come on give me the thing
well there was no debate about that what
was it jostling a little jiggle when I
was doing the cheese physics calculation
such [ __ ] everyone knows that
logical cheese physics don't do this
just oh oh I was looking to see what I
was doing and I wasn't concentrating on
the [ __ ] that was in front of my
frickin face I got caught by a fart at
the last second a fart flew by my
I gotta shut up I don't care anymore
[ __ ] your Ford
oh [ __ ] your fart oh [ __ ] your fart with
reckless abandon [ __ ] your stupid
[ __ ] fart your stupid F [ __ ] these
are literal a splint [ __ ] Oh your
rhythmic [ __ ]
oh you rhythmic [ __ ] know what
Oh eat a dick 800 dicks eat a thousand
Dixon the world's greatest ass and I
don't have to I can't [ __ ] you
jaw this better work better frickin work
there we go
die die I'm done I did it I did it I
thought this is gonna be a fun
experience and then I started ranting
about cheese physics and foot farts
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] as well as I did
you know it okay so thank you everybody
so much for watching this has been
murder the king thank you everyone who's
suggested you're an [ __ ]
not really I love you mwah much love and
love and love and love in love in love
and farts so thanks again and as always
I'll see you in the next video
exactly yeah there you go yeah there we
go